hey guys wanted to talk about any
Blackburn today after her mention in the
last episode of twin peak season 3 part
7 this will have spoilers for the secret
history of Twin Peaks if you haven't
read that book yet but it is pretty
important information and I don't know
that this would actually spoil the whole
book experience or anything like that to
proceed with caution if you're planning
on reading the book tomorrow or
something like that alright so let's
start out with what we know about Annie
from the television show and the movie
any Blackburn is played by Heather
Graham and we learned that in her senior
year of high school she was in a
relationship that ended badly
and then she attempted suicide after
that she moved into a convent for five
years she eventually left there and came
back to her hometown of Twin Peaks and
went to see her sister Norma at the
Double R she ends up getting a job there
she ends up meeting Cooper there and I
won't get into all the details of their
courting but they basically fell
head-over-heels in love as their romance
was blossoming she ended up winning the
Miss Twin Peaks contest at the end of
season two then being kidnapped by
Windom Earle and taken into the Red Room
with him by entering the portal at
Glastonbury Grove agent Cooper pursued
them and this is more or less how we got
to where we are now with Cooper's
doppelganger and everything else that's
happened in the Red Room
she left the Red Room with what we what
she thought was Cooper but in reality we
know it was evil Cooper she turned up in
fire walk with me in a dream to deliver
the message to Laura that we got through
her diary pages in part 7 of season 3
her message was that you know her name
was Annie Blackburn that she's been with
Dale the good Dale is in the lodge and
he can't leave and so on so forth there
was also a cutscene included in the
missing pieces DVD extra where we saw a
nurse take the al cave ring from her as
she's being wheeled into the hospital
and that's what we've seen of Annie on
screen and it's absolutely worth
mentioning that even though she came
into the series late she had
firmly intertwined into the story
because of our relationship with coop
and their trip behind the red curtain
most of what happened in the back end of
season two is not necessarily important
to what's going on now but she was
certainly one of the most important
characters this is why it was a really
big shock when she wasn't listed as one
of the returning cast for season three
people noticed that right away because
everybody's been wondering what happened
to Annie and there were evening
interviews where Heather Graham was
asked about if she was returning and
basically said she would have loved to
reprise the role but she just wasn't
asked if she just never heard any news
about being in the new season then the
secret history of Twin Peaks was
released in some details directly
related to Amy caught everyone's
attention pretty much as soon as they
read it so I talked about the secret
history of Twin Peaks quite a bit and
there is a lot of really important
information in this book as it's related
to the overall story of both the
original run and what's going on in
season three right now I recommend it if
you haven't seen it or looked at over
whatever there was there's always a link
in my description to my video
descriptions to check it out on Amazon
but anyways it came out after the
filming of season three was already
complete like it was written by Mark
Frost who's the co-creator of Twin Peaks
separately from David Lynch but they had
been coordinating at the same time to
shoot the scenes for season three and
write the seasons episodes and all that
stuff so it wasn't released until after
after all that stuff was done so there
was quite a few things that were
contradictory two things we had already
seen on-screen in seasons 1 & 2 and the
first thing related to Annie that was
odd was that there's like a extra
biography of Norma Norma Jennings who
runs the double R which doesn't really
need to be there otherwise but anyways
in this version of Norma her maiden name
was
instrum she had a mother named Elsa and
a father named Marty and there isn't any
mention of having a little sister named
Annie whatsoever now since you probably
watch season two you're thinking well
what about the one that we saw in the
show her mother and the shows she was in
several episodes right yeah her mom was
supposed to be a food critic who went by
the pen name of MT Wentz and if you
remember at that time everyone to Double
R was trying to go the extra mile just
in case this famous writer and critic
came in to eat so that they could get a
good review yeah her name was Vivian
Smythe Niles
she came with that guy Ernie who had no
Hank from prison and I don't think
that's all that important but it was a
part of show canon that that was Norma's
mother then the secret history comes out
and she has a different mother mark
frost was asked about this and basically
he acknowledged that there that is
different and he wasn't going to say
anything else more about it we'd have to
wait and see what the explanation was
there was also some rewriting of that
miss Twin Peaks contest I spoke about
earlier mark frost has said when asked
about this that Lana had won the Miss
Twin Peaks contest so she was basically
either stripped of her crown or
something else happened in that Lana
eventually became the queen
so I there's a lot of just wild
speculation we can make here but I think
it's really interesting that in part
seven it is by saying that I mean Hawk
didn't have to say that Annie Blackburn
was who wrote that letter they if they
wanted to write any out of the series
for some reason you wouldn't mention her
name but he did so this makes a big
problem we have the one version of Annie
that we saw Norma's little sister that
fell in love with Cooper went into the
Red Room came out was in the hospital
and now is seemingly nowhere to be found
and then we have this history of Twin
Peaks where she wasn't the queen of the
pageant we saw her win and she wasn't in
the same family that we know that she
should be in so this is the
I am NOT here to answer or solve the
problem I'm here to bring it up and
start a discussion now there are some
pretty wild theories out there and you
have the kind of wild theories that are
written well and can you can kind of
jump in to the one that stands out the
most to me is season three is an
alternate reality or an alternate
universe I'm not advocating that that's
what's going on I'm just saying that if
you read that theory it's pretty well
put together but you know the bottom
line is we have a character she exists
in our universe and we don't have a
great idea of why all this revision has
come into play she could be and could
have always been somebody who was put
into the world by the guys in the lodges
to Laura Cooper in but how do we get
from there to here Hawk knows who she is
but does Norma you know it's very
confusing let me know what you think
please like the video and subscribe to
my channel I'm going to be trying to do
more bonus videos like this in the
coming weeks so let me know some
feedback let me know what you want to
see thanks for watching and I'll talk to
you soon